i think a lot of pundits are trying to
come out with a clear sense of it's
going to be all this it's going to be
all that it's the answer is it's going
to be some of everything you know and
clearly it's it changes depending on
what the workflow is and who we are you
know
i don't think all of one thing an old
another thing is healthy and clearly you
know going back to the office benefits
extroverts and introverts are a little
happier to stay home you know uh staying
out of the office has some benefits it's
it's a mixed bag i think one of the
things it will do this i think is a very
good thing is it will produce a
flexibility that we didn't have before
so even an office that may have been
friendly to at-home work you know not
all offices were
those that weren't will become more
friendly to it but even those that were
there was still a permission required
like hey is it okay if i work from home
next friday because my kids got a thing
that i got to be home for you know um
where now we come you know just waking
up in the morning and sending out a note
to everybody saying hey i'm working from
home today and everybody's fine with it
i think i think the level of flexibility
and accountability and self-control
actually factor in it also produces a
whole a whole slew of new challenges
which which is and i think unresolved i
think i don't think anybody's really has
a theory on this yet which is what's the
definition of a full-time job
right so full-time job used to mean
i come in at you know in the morning and
i leave in
the late afternoon early evening
and that's it and what i do in the
evenings and weekends is mine
but now
what if i want to wake up at noon and
work till eight
and then i or what happens if i wanna
have another job
well like well we pay your insurance but
i don't necessarily work during work
hours anymore as long as i'm available
my work isn't suffering you know i used
to be able to do whatever i wanted in my
free time which was evenings and
weekends now free time is not clearly
defined it's not clearly delineated
anymore so i think one of the things
that has yet to settle
is what is the definition of full-time
employment and how do we measure and how
do we say you can or can't do other
things outside of your job i i think
that's fascinating